there's only a few more days until
Christmas and Shoppers aren't wasting
any time a Valley Mall though they're
bracing for the last minute rush from
both locals as well as tourists
I want to be home before five o'clock so
I gotta get some coffee in there or
something oh my gosh I've had one and I
think I'm running on fumes the clock is
ticking until Christmas and holiday
Shoppers like Selena Cohen know there is
still so much to do and not enough time
I wish it was the last this is like the
first Christmas shopping that I've been
working for like three weeks straight
China
trying to get prepared for this and
you're never prepared on Thursday the
Las Vegas Premium Outlets were packed
Shoppers waiting in long lines inside
their favorite retailer While others
walked away with their hands full
consumers are expected to spend on
average 832 dollars this holiday season
despite inflation according to the
National Retail Federation nevadans
expected to spend eight percent more
this year there's a lot of good deals
out here that um
that will catch people's eye except for
the last last minute Shoppers here you
can do the whole touch feel try and buy
experience and get to go home with your
gifts Ashley Fawcett with the Las Vegas
Premium Outlet says Shoppers here can
not only explore all 175 retailers but
also get free parking for locals
seasonal Staffing she says also up to
speed to help keep the flow going I got
a couple of pairs of shoes which I
wasn't anticipating on but I could and
pass up the deal for this Shopper
in-store is her best option to avoid
late deliveries it's a hard conversation
all right so also keep in mind most
retailers will be extending their hours
and expect the day after Christmas to be
very busy as well with many using gift
cards and trying to find day after
Christmas deals the Las Vegas Premium
Outlets extend their hours from nine to
nine to better serve all of their
customers